Film Courage: Well I know you said that you
appreciate USC because the people in the documentary
[referring to an earlier video of people going
to a competitive graduate writing program]
said they also appreciated the school (they
still have nothing but respect for it) but
it was a very excruciating process and one
of the teachers even said “Well, if you
think this is difficult [the curriculum],
try being in the real world.”
Sort of this breeding ground, who is going
to make it, who is not.
And some people didn’t make it.
I was wondering how that was for you because
it sounds like you have a very supportive
family and you came from a college where you
got your four year degree.
What advice would you give to someone who
is coming here and they know that this is
just what they have to go through, it’s
not intentional, they are not trying to be
mean.
Justin Warren, filmmaker: I’d say don’t
quit because it’s super easy to get discouraged
and to feel bitter and feel like “Oh these
people don’t get me.”
But the great part is that it does force you
to examine what you’re doing, to examine
your intention in your work, to sharpen it
so it’s the clearest, most precise version
of what you’re trying to do.
And when you realize…when you take your
ego out of the process and you go into a note
session thinking “Okay, I’m just here
to get information.
That information is so I can prove my work.”
It’s not going there to get validation that
your good at what you do, that’s not what
that process is for.
Think of it as a process of whittling it down,
you’re whittling a stick into something
sharp.
And then when you’re done with that whittling
process then you can sort of release to the
world and have it be something that your proud
of hopefully and that process is so critical
because when I think about how I used to work
as an artist, as a creator before my film
school experience, I would…if I was going
to make a short or something…because I made
a short before I went to school…and I made
one cut and that was it.
I was like “Oh, cool.
I’m done.”
Because it wa right there, I did it.
But then you realize that in film school that’s
where it begins.
That’s where the work starts is on your
first try where you thought you crushed it
and you realize “Oh, I actually didn’t
crush it at all?”
And that sense of kind of humility that come
with the craft is a really beautiful place
to be in (at least I feel that way).
And I now love that process.
But it’s unfortunate because I saw some
of my friends didn’t make it in the program
because they were getting so much harsh feedback,
I think they started to take it personally
and they started to think”Well nobody gets
what I’m doing” and so they dropped out
of the program.
And that’s very unfortunate.
I mean I’m not saying that staying in…everybody
has their own path that’s what is best for
them, but when I wanted to quit, I was really,
really, grateful that I didn’t.because if
I would have quit right after that session
where I wept bitterly, I would have relieved
myself of some short term pain but I would
not be nearly the filmmaker that I am now.
And the great part also about the notes process
is that it keeps you humble in the sense that
there is so much that you don’t know and
there is so much to be explored that the journey
to booming a good filmmaker or a good writer
is a lifelong process and wherever you are
in the process, that’s just where you are.
And I’m grateful to the point where I’m
just now like “Okay, I’m going to try
something new and I might fail but I’ve
gotten through failure before and I’m still
here so I know that I can get through it.